[Musique]
2020 jamais depuis sa création le cinéma
n'aura été plongés dans une telle
obscurité la 46e cérémonie des césar
sera l'occasion de célébrer un cinéma
durement touchée mais debout vivant
alors oui on sera peut-être un peu moins
légers on verra peut-être un peu moins
d'habitude nom sera là en sang
j'ai put est en marche
la 46e cérémonie des césar c'est le
vendredi 12 mars à 21h en clair en
direct et en exclusivité sur canal+
comme un hommage
j'ai lancé la mode et j'ai été récupérés
alors maxime donc les césars étroite et
n'a plus donné évidemment ça va avoir
lieu
tourné à l'olympia à la sauce ne sais
pas si ce sera en public ou pas est-ce
que les remettants seront là juste pour
récupérer leur trophée
c'est alors la question qui est suspendu
et concernant la bande annonce
le c'est parfait il ya le ton qui est
grave parce que le cinéma est une
industrie qui a été durement touchée
mais en même temps il y est c'est cet
humour avec ce père rien de mieux qu
après on vous le dit et puis à
l'intérieur de la bande annonce qui dure
une minute 40 il ya un hommage aussi à
annie girardot
je ne sais pas si je vous ai manqué un
mémoire on m'avait beaucoup manqué mon
cas ça et puis il ya à la fois dans son
personnage comique un peu sérieux et
dramatique donc ce sera parfait pour
avoir les deux tempéraments soda par m
la première annonce alors vous voulez
mais rien aujourd'hui je vais vous dire
la bande-annonce est réussie parce que
elle est ratée comme la cérémonie césar
chaque année juste que je pense voilà
c'est nul
à chaque année je regarde regarde pas ce
que je regarde par professionnalisme
font c'est bon c'est une cérémonie
anxiogène congratule entre eux ils
disent que c'est un cirque où vers l'or
qui n'a pas pu le faire mais que le
service cinéma bon bref je déteste le
bout en bout pour et en plus si vous
regardez là je parle un peu à moi je les
lis si vous regardez la courbe
d'audience elle s'étiole d'année en
année ça veut dire que les
téléspectateurs ont compris qu'ils
n'étaient pas impliqués de non non vous
remarquerez la liberté de canal+ que les
césar
je vous dis à bientôt j'adore c'est tout
ce que j'aime cette bande-annonce le
choix des mots justes les beaux mots
marina foïs qui arrive très
hollywoodienne très glamour et à la fin
comme elle se ramasse comme une merde
sur metal et on n'a pas laissé toute la
fois parce qu'elle est au téléphone en
disant [ __ ] je lui ferai comme
d'habitude ça c'est exceptionnel et ça
donne tellement bien le ton je pense
qu'après florence foresti pour la 46e
cérémonie des césars n'y avait pas mieux
que marine on retrouve un peu l'esprit
canal tu seras d'accord et moi je dis là
on revient on était loin des bruits mais
on retrouve à l'heure qu'il est je
trouve que en ce moment les gens ont
besoin de voir sur le web et sur le mois
les six à sept savourer ça vous avez dix
ans aujourd'hui ils ont besoin sur les
trous il ses camarades non excusez moi
mais moi je pense qu'ils ont le courage
de faire ça et je trouve ça très très
bien de se remettre un peu en cas
d'exode moderne
j'adore et je dois castle être une vraie
cinéphile est allé au cinéma donne le
tournis à parme en belgique on aime
beaucoup
donc c'est normal habitude mais vraiment
je suis désolé cinéma c'est drôle aussi
mais oui mais pas comme maman